Apple just released their M3 M3 Pro and
M3 Max Max and they look amazing but
there were 20 things that Apple did not
mention at their event they were very
sneaky this time so I have a lot more
secrets than normal so let's go ahead
and jump right into them the first one
has got to do with the 13-in M2 MacBook
Pro previously they would keep older
generation ones available for a while
just at a lower price but this time they
completely got rid of it without telling
us and that means that the seven years
of touch bar are finally over and for
number two we have the replacement for
the 13 which is the same 14in but with
the M3 processor now and it comes with a
single fan that they showed us but
didn't tell us so if you get the M3 you
have one less fan which could be fine
but the other thing they didn't mention
here is that it gets two nand chips
instead of one on the the previous
smaller cheaper MacBook Pro and that
means that the issues we had with
multitasking are now completely fixed
and they did that by giving us 512 gigs
as standard instead of
256 which is great now as for number
three even though that $1,600 price tag
seems like a big jump from the previous
1300 if you actually do the math and you
upgrade to 512 which we recommended to
pretty much everybody because of that
issue that is only a $1100 price
difference and for that you get a lot of
extras like the better webcam the new
design the amazing display much better
speakers and of course you have more
ports plus the SD card slots which is a
great deal for $100 more let alone
getting the M3 processor and for the
fourth secret that Apple didn't mention
is that even though we have Thunderbolt
ports and an HDMI which is great the
14-in M3 MacBook still only support one
external display just like the M1
MacBook Air that you could still buy
brand new for as low as
$750 on Amazon I thought for sure the M3
chips would support too but nope and
that does suck and for number five that
HDMI port is not as powerful as the M3
Pros or even the one that came on the M2
Pro 14in for the same amount as this M3
version those support 4K up to 240 Herz
or 8K up to 60 HZ but this M3 version
it's actually limited to 6K 60 HZ which
is okay and also 4K 120 so it is not as
powerful as far as refresh rates or
resolution not a huge deal but Apple did
not mention that and for number six this
one sucks more and that is the fact that
the 14in M3 has one less Thunderbolt
port and I completely didn't see that
until way later so instead of having
three thund bolt ports like we've had
the whole time we've had 14-in MacBooks
you get two and the port that they got
rid of is on the right hand side so now
we just have that HDMI and SD card slot
and I kind of wish if they had to get
rid of one of those they would have got
rid of the one on the left so you can
have the flexibility of choosing which
side to plug into or even better just
make it a regular USB type-c if it
couldn't support it number seven has got
to do with charging we now get a 70 W
USBC power adapter with the base models
and not only the
m3600 one if you get a $2,000 one you
still get an adapter that cannot fast
charge the laptop you have to go in and
spend $20 more to get a fast charger or
spend at least
$2,200 on an unbinned version of an M3
Pro to get it which kind of sucks
because if you want to buy a Macbook
right now the ones are going to be kept
in stock online and in store they they
will not have that so you have to custom
order number eight has got to do with
battery life and batteries in general
now I saw that the M3 has a 70w battery
compared to
72.4 but what changed wasn't the M3
cheaper version in fact if you're
getting an M3 Pro or Max they actually
made the battery capacity larger than in
the previous 14in models and maybe they
did that to help with battery life to
keep it the same because this time if
you get an M3 you will get up to 22
hours of uh video playback like they
showed off on stage compared to 18 hours
for the more professional chips and then
for web use you will get 15 hours
compared to 12 so we definitely have
better battery life with the M3 chip for
number nine you can now only get 8 tab
of storage if you buy an M3 Max whereas
previously you could get a pro chip and
get a terabyte so if you you had the
cash and you don't need extra
performance but a lot of storage well
before you didn't have to upgrade your
chips this time you have to and that's
going to cost a lot more money now the
next one is about the color options the
way Apple presented the new space black
at the event and made it seem like an
exclusive for the M3 Max 16-in models
but nope you can even get a Basse M3 Pro
and get space black which surprised me
when I looked at the configurator now
with that if you want to get Space gray
on the higher-end laptops you can no
longer do that and then this way it also
means that if you have a space grade
people will know that either you have an
old Mac or you have the new cheap one
number 11 has got to do with their
accessories and we thought for sure with
everything switching to USBC Apple would
update them but nope the keyboard and
the mouse still come with a lightning
port and the lightning cables which
seems insane being almost
20204 4 for number 12 even though Apple
gave us relatively good deals on the
base 14-in model they actually raised
the top spec M3 Max it used to always be
$3,500 for that setup but now it is
$44,000 if you want the full performance
that they advertised at the event and
now costs a mass of
7,500 if you spec it out all the way
with that for number 13 the M3 Max that
is banned now cost $ 3,5 00 and it gives
you a 30 core GPU whereas the 30 core M2
Max version used to cost you
3,300 so you get the same amount of
cores but you pay more money and for the
next one number 14 the CPU on the N3 Max
is now bined as well which it never used
to so before you could save money and
get the weaker graphics with the same
CPU performance but now you have to
spend more money even if you have no use
for extra graphics performance for
number 15 we're going to jump back to
the M2 Pro and while prices have not
changed performance unfortunately has
even though these are all now 3
nanometer designs and the M3 and the M3
Max now have more transistors packed in
with the M3 Pro it actually went down
this year to 37 billion transistors
compared to 40 billion with the M2 Pro
and this is probably why Apple kept
comparing the M3 Pro to just the M1 Pro
and for 16 as far as the CPU cores when
you look you still see a total of 12
cores like before but instead of eight
performance cores and four efficiency
cores with the M3 Pro they got rid of
two performance cores this year and they
swapped it with efficiency which is why
when Apple was talking about the M3
Pro's performance and they said it was
20% faster they compared it to the M1
Pro because the M2 2 Pro was also 20%
faster than the M1 Pro and that means
that this year with the M3 Pro it is not
any faster in terms of CPU than last
generations and that is crazy and for 17
the M3 Pro's Graphics now has one less
core compared to last year so from 19
down to 18 Graphics cores and
technically it could be 20 because the
pro chip always had half of the graphics
cores of the max ship but this time they
made it different likely to save money
because they did not raise prices like
they did with the M3 Max and for 18
another way that they saved money is
with the memory now when you look at it
you see 18 gigs of RAM compared to 16 so
it seems like a nice sweet free upgrade
but the M3 pro has 150 GB per second
bandwidth compared to 200 GB per second
for the M2 Pro and even the m M1 Pro now
they did this by using one less memory
Channel and using less chips which saves
them money and based on the way Apple
wrote it you cannot get back to that 200
they had before by upgrading your RAM
which really sucks and for 19 the M3
Max's bin version also drops down and
now has 300 GB per second bandwidth
compared to 400 so 25% less bandwidth
which is how much memory can go through
at one time now in previous years they
made a huge deal about bandwidth it was
right there on the main page but now
they don't even talk about it at all on
that page or even on the full spec page
and you only see it using the compare
tool and of course when Apple showed off
performance increases they talk about
the full speec chip and for 20 the nice
thing is that if you do spend $500 more
on the M3 Max you actually go back to
the standard 400 GB per second bandwidth
that we have seen for multiple
Generations ever since Apple silicon
came to the these new redesigned
MacBooks so you can't fix it there but
by spending 500 bucks and that does suck
that we're having that issue now of
course we ordered a ton of different
MacBooks so we will see how these kind
of capped and bend and worse versions
perform to the better ones and the last
generation because in certain tasks they
could actually be slower so make sure to
click that Circle but to subscribe in
the notifications down below so you guys
do not miss that check out one of those
great videos right over there this has
been Max and I will see you in the next
[Music]
one